ready to have your mind blown by those
expert purveyors of heavy sci-fi the
Wachowski and an all-star cast Netflix
is about to add a movie that may
interest you
2012's Cloud Atlas will be available to
watch on the streamer starting on July
1st 2020 and if you've never seen it
you're in for a treat for that matter if
you have seen it you'll probably want to
watch it again because getting your head
all the way around the movie upon first
viewing is no small feat it's also no
small feat to provide a synopsis for
this movie it's an absolutely sprawling
work telling a series of interconnected
stories which take place over the course
of nearly five centuries every member of
the main cast plays multiple roles as
the movie jumps across different time
periods many of them at times appear in
heavy makeup with a different actor
filling the story's lead role after each
time jump love it or hate it critics
agree that Cloud Atlas is a wildly
unconventional film it's an outcome one
might have expected from an adaptation
of author David Mitchell's similarly
dense an ambitious 2004 novel it's also
the only one of the Wachowskis films on
which they collaborated with another
credited writer and director Tom tickler
tickler is the filmmaker behind the
visionary cult film Run Lola Run who
also worked with the sisters on their
own cult favorite Netflix series sense8
on top of having three directors
steering the ship Cloud Atlas also
sports a ridiculously stacked cast and
they all acquit themselves quite well
despite the fact that they're each
tasked with filming five or six distinct
roles the film takes place in six
different time periods with the first
segment opening in the Pacific Islands
in 18-49 from there Cloud Atlas jumps
forward in time to 1936 and then to 1973
2012
21:44 and finally all the way to 23 21
each new story connects with the one
that came before it and the characters
actions in one story continue to
influence events decades into the future
our lives are not our own
from womb to tomb we are bound to others
but in spite of the caste and the
involvement of the Wachowskis Cloud
Atlas was a significant flop upon its
release the 100 million dollar picture
managed only about 130 million dollars
at the worldwide box office which
amounted to a substantial loss for
Warner Brothers once marketing and
promotion costs were figured Adam the
film likely wasn't helped by the
complexity of its narrative and utter
refusal to hold the hands of its
audience not to mention its nearly 3
hour runtime of course while such
complaints can help to sync a film's
theatrical performance they're often
mitigated by the home viewing experience
so if the movie's length dissuaded you
from catching it in the theatre here's
your chance to give it the day on court
it deserves the flick received mixed to
positive reviews but among those critics
to offer virtually unreserved praise was
the great Roger Ebert who passed away
only six months after its release and
has forced our review Ebert wrote I was
never ever bored by Cloud Atlas
oh what a film this is and what a
demonstration of the magical dreamlike
qualities of the cinema now it's
understandable that some may question
whether another Cloud Atlas movie is in
the cards even with how divisive it was
amongst critics when it first debuted
while there haven't been any talks about
making a straight-up sequel fans of the
film may take hard and knowing that the
book upon which it's based is one of
many penned by author David Mitchell the
British writer released two novels
following Cloud Atlas 2014's the bone
clocks and 2015's Slade house both of
which are said to be subtly connected to
Cloud Atlas in October 2015
The Daily Beast even described Slade
house as a quote scary new sequel to
Cloud Atlas as well as a sequel of sorts
to bone clocks considering they're all
connected whether either of these novels
get the film adaptation treatment in the
future remains to be seen but if they do
Mitchell may very well be supportive of
it after all he went on record in
October 2012 to express his satisfaction
with what the Wachowskis and tick were
had done in adapting his work in a post
published to The Wall Street Journal
Mitchell wrote adaptation is a form of
translation and all acts of translation
have to deal with untranslatable spots
when asked whether I mind the changes
made during the adaptation of Cloud
Atlas
my response is this the filmmakers speak
fluent film language and they've done
what works check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]